Heute im Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf Anderlein.
Fluminense gewinnt die Copa Libertadores, die südamerikanische Variante der Champions League und das zum ersten Mal in der Vereinsgeschichte. Wir wollen blicken auf dieses Finale und wir wollen blicken auf das ganze Turnier. Herzlich willkommen hier in der Ligatur des Rasenfunks. Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und schön, dass ich hier zwei Gäste begrüßen kann. Zum einen Johannes Skiba. Er ist freier Journalist, unter anderem für die TZ. Er kommentiert auf Sport total TV, er schreibt bei ihr Freunde und er hat den Podcast Goal Olympico. Und irgendwie habe ich den Eindruck, das könnte mit unserem Thema hier zusammenhängen. Hallo Johannes, schön, dass du hier mal im Rasenfunk bist.
Ja, hi, vielen, vielen Dank für die Einladung. Ich freue mich wahnsinnig, dass wir hier über den Fußball in Südamerika reden können, über die Libertadores. Für mich der geilste Fußballwettbewerb überhaupt. Und ja, ich habe richtig Bock.
Sehr gut. Ich bin auch richtig pumped, muss ich sagen. Da hat dieses Intro auch ein bisschen geholfen, dass ich in der Pre-Production noch mal runterleveln musste. Das war dann doch ein bisschen zu laut in der Ursprungsvariante. Das wundert den Dritten hier in der Runde gar nicht. Andreas Geipel, den kennt ihr auch schon. Wir haben ja schon mal über die Copa gesprochen. Das ist allerdings jetzt schon –und dafür schäme ich mich –fünf Jahre her. Das war der Superklassico damals im Finale. Damals war Andreas hier schon zu Gast. Er ist Filmemacher und hat mehrere tolle Filme schon veröffentlicht, unter anderem auch zum südamerikanischen Fußball. Ich freue mich sehr, dass er hier ist. Hallo Andreas.
Hallo Max, vielen Dank für die Einladung und schöne Runde, auch dass ich Johannes mal wieder hier habe. Ich habe Marte dabei, ich sehe deinen nicht, euren auch nicht.
Ich habe hier den guten alten Kaffee. Ich mache es heute kolumbianisch.
Geht auch. Ich freue mich auf jeden Fall. Ich bin mal gespannt, was jetzt rauskommt in die nächste Stunde.
Ich bin auch gespannt. Es ist eigentlich eine Mammut-Aufgabe. Dieses Turnier, also jetzt allein nur diese Ausgabe dieses Turniers zu besprechen. Johannes, weil du jetzt schon so ein Plädoyer fast schon gehalten hast, was macht denn die Copa aus?
Naja, da muss man ein bisschen größer greifen, glaube ich. Einfach der südamerikanische Fußball ist ja an sich, ich bezeichne das tatsächlich immer so als eine besondere kulturelle Ausprägung, die Südamerika quasi dem Fußball gegeben hat über 100 Jahre oder wie auch immer. Und natürlich sind das ganz vorneweg einfach die Fans, die dieses Spiel so leben wie vielleicht nirgendwo auf der Welt. Das sind die Fangesänge, das sind ganze Orchester, die da mit in den Popos stehen, in den Fankurven stehen. Das sind Choreos und das ist einfach eine ganz besondere Leidenschaft, die die südamerikanischen Fußballfans da haben. Und das überträgt sich natürlich auch auf die Teams, auf die Trainer, auf die Berichterstattung, die auch eine ganz besondere ist. Und das ist so als Gesamtpaket fantastisch. Und der Wettbewerb, die Libertadores, das ist natürlich ein sehr historischer Wettbewerb. Früher noch viel mehr als leider heutzutage. Dann natürlich auch am Ende so dieses Kräftemessen mit den europäischen Mannschaften, wenn es dann zum Weltpokal gegangen ist und so weiter. Und ja, aber für viele Spieler aus Südamerika, oder die meisten, ist das das Nonplusultra. Erstmal, wenn man sowohl seine Karriere beginnt, als auch wenn man seine Karriere beendet, wenn man quasi wieder diesen Schritt zurück nach Südamerika geht, da nochmal diesen Pokal zu gewinnen. Und wenn man diesen Pokal auch sieht, der ist ja sehr, sehr mächtig, sehr, sehr groß, über zwölf Kilo, glaube ich, schwer. Ja, und das ist einfach so ein Gesamtkunstwerk dieser Wettbewerb, würde ich sagen.
Andreas hat viel genickt, dir geht es offenbar ähnlich.
Ja, also vor allem, ich glaube, die eindrucksvolle Szene war ja dieser, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie alt er wohl war, sagen wir mal, der war zwölf, dieser zwölfjährige Junge im mitten diesem Bukapulk an dem, also dieser hier Copacabana und dergleichen, die ganzen Strände waren ja voll von Bukatsunas Fans. Und dann war ja dieser Junge mit seinem Papa und sagte, ey, ich habe meine PlayStation verhökert, mein Papa hat sein Motorrad verhökert, um hierher zu kommen und wir haben nur nicht mal eine Eintrittskarte. Und er hat das aber mit so einer Leidenschaft gesagt und halt auch, weiß nicht, Puls 180 und diese typische Latinofeurigkeit in den Augen und in der Stimme. Und da hat man, glaube ich, auch, ja, da kriegt man schon mal so eine Idee, was das für die eigentlich bedeutet. Was das für eine Fahrt ist. Dann ist natürlich Rio auch eine geile Stadt. Die Leute sind eigentlich auch ganz cool, auch wenn es mit der Polizei da jetzt ein bisschen Probleme gab. Aber an sich ist das natürlich ein absolutes Fußballfest und wird halt dementsprechend zelebriert.
100.000 Fans von Bocca waren in Rio de Janeiro. Fluminense durfte in seiner Stadt versuchen, das erste Mal diesen Titel zu gewinnen. Bocca hat versucht, mit Independiente gleichzuziehen, die ja seit den 80ern Rekordtitelträger in diesem Wettbewerb sind. Bocca hat aber auch seit 2007 schon die Copa nicht mehr gewonnen. Also sehr, sehr viele Emotionen. Ich habe auch in der Übertragung gemerkt, ich habe selten so viele Menschen beten sehen bei den Hymnen, die hier gespielt wurden. Und auch, dass man Menschen weinen sieht, ist jetzt nicht so ungewöhnlich, dass es aber so gleich verteilt ist, obwohl einer von beiden ja gewonnen hat am Ende. Na ja, also das, was ihr gesagt habt, mal 100.000. Es ist einfach ein sehr, sehr emotionaler Wettbewerb. Auch mit negativen Seiten, die gibt es auch. Ich denke, da werden wir heute auch kurz drüber sprechen. Aber wir wollen nicht das Negative überbetonen. Diesen Fehler, den man ja manchmal macht, wenn man auf den südamerikanischen Fußball blickt. Denn es gibt auch ganz, ganz viel Schönes. Auf das wollen wir gleich blicken. Vorher aber erst noch der Hinweis. Der Rasenfunk ist Paywall-Werbe und sponsorunfrei. Wir sind rein crowdfinanziert. Wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Jeder Euro hilft und geht auch an die Gäste. Ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die uns schon unterstützen, die möglich machen, dass wir solche Sendungen hier machen. Das geht ehrlicherweise nur deshalb, weil ich keinen anderen Job habe und dann einfach eben das hier als, glaube ich, fünfte Sendung jetzt dann in dieser Woche einfach reinschieben kann. Also ganz herzlichen Dank. Ihr habt quasi mit eurer Unterstützung diese Sendung möglich gemacht. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Jetzt blicken wir mal auf dieses Finale. Ich habe schon ein bisschen die Rahmenbedingungen genannt. Boca, natürlich ein sehr bekannter Verein, Fluminense, sicher auch gehört zu den großen Zwölf der brasilianischen Vereine, ist aber mit Botafogo der einzige, der eben noch nie die Copa gewinnen konnte und das als ältester Verein Rio de Janeiro 1902 gegründet. Und jetzt aber war es soweit. Dem 1 zu 0 in der 38. Minute, Entschuldigung, von Cano, folgt noch der Ausgleich von Atvin Kula in der 72. Minute. Der wurde mal einfach so überhaupt gar nicht angegriffen, als er nach innen gezogen ist, um zu schießen. Und dann kam das, was wir schon im Intro gehört haben. John Kennedy, oder Canagi, wie er es da ausgesprochen wurde, macht in der 99. Minute wirklich ein wunderbares Tor. Ein wunderbares Tor. Er geht zum Jubeln in die eigene Fan-Kurve, sieht dafür dann die zweite gelbe Karte. Also er fliegt unmittelbar nach seinem Tor mit gelb-rot vom Platz. Es gibt eine weitere rote Karte gegen Frank Fabra, dann gegen Ende der ersten Hälfte der Verlängerung. Und obwohl Bocca alles versucht, gelingt kein weiterer Treffer. Fluminense trifft noch einmal den Pfosten. Und so wird jetzt Fluminense de Rio de Janeiro tatsächlich Copa-Sieger. Hat es geschafft zum ersten Mal in seiner Vereinsgeschichte. Johannes, ist dann das auch der verdiente Sieger dieses Wettbewerbs?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich meine, das Finale war das Finale der Gegensätze. Du hast schon gesagt, wenn man auf die Historie blickt, aber eben auch voll im Spielstil. Fernando Dinis ist Trainer seit April 2022, ist jetzt mindestens ein Jahr Coach der brasilianischen Nationalmannschaft. Das ist ja schon mal ohne zu wissen, wer das genau ist, auf jeden Fall mal eine Ansage. Er ist der, der den Brasilianern ein bisschen dieses Spielgefühl, was man früher als Joga Bonito bezeichnet hat und auch dann, wodurch es bekannt wurde, das so ein bisschen zurückbringt, eine eigene Spielidentität einfach entwickelt mit seinen taktischen Ansätzen, die es so eigentlich noch nicht gibt. Die Presse nennt das den Dinizismo. Und wenn man eben das Spiel so revolutioniert, würde ich tatsächlich sagen, und das eben auch erfolgreich ist, dann ist das so in der Gesamtheit erstmal auf jeden Fall verdient. Die K.O.-Spiele, da war Fluminense in jedem Spiel überlegen und auch im Finale. Ja, es war klar, dass Burka da eher kompakt stehen will und jetzt nicht diesen Angriffspfussball zelebrieren kann. Das können sie einfach nicht. Oder hat Almiron seitdem er Trainer ist überhaupt auch nicht spielen lassen. Das war schon so zu erwarten, dass Fluminense da das Spiel macht. Und das haben sie gemacht. Und ich denke, das ist schon verdient. Wobei man sich auch nicht hätte beschwerden dürfen, wenn es dann doch ins Elfmeterschießen geht und Burka dann doch eben gewinnt. Im Elfmeterexperten sind sie ja. Aber ich finde, dass es, wenn man den ganzen Wettbewerb betrachtet, ist Fluminense der verdiente Sieger und auch eine sympathische Mannschaft, ein fantastischer Trainer und zwei, drei sehr interessante spezielle Charaktere im Team. Fluminense gefällt mir auf jeden Fall.
Ja, ich muss ehrlicherweise zugeben, ich bin ja noch mal immer für die argentinischen Mannschaften. Dieses Mal war es aber tatsächlich so, dass ich wollte, dass Fluminense gewinnt. Einfach, weil das über den ganzen Turnierverlauf die attraktivste Mannschaft war. Du kannst da echt gut zugucken, wie Jo auch gerade eben schon gesagt hat, haben echt ein paar tolle Einzelspieler, aber das Kollektiv ist wahnsinnig gut. Also wie die halt zusammen kombinieren, den Gegner teilweise auch auseinandernehmen können, aber dann halt auch relativ solide verteidigen können. Und wenn man das jetzt gerade mit Bukka vergleicht, Bukka-Junas ist seit vielen Jahren eigentlich –das kann man sich schwer angucken, ob das jetzt Liga ist, ob das international ist. Da hat vielleicht jetzt auch der ein oder andere noch gefehlt, so mit Marcos Rojo als Abwehrchef und Cevachos als einer, der so ein Youngster, so ein Flügelstürmer, der mal ein 1 gegen 1 auch gut gehen kann. Und diese Youngster, die sie sonst noch haben, wie Christian Medina und Valentin Bako, waren eigentlich auch schwach, fand ich, im Finale. Und irgendwie, da war schon ein Klassenunterschied da. Auch so, ich weiß nicht, so generell. Bukka, das ist keine Mannschaft. Und deswegen, also dass das mal aus meinem Mund kommt, dass ich will, nachdem die letzten Jahre die Brasilianer so dominiert haben. Aber ich konnte mir das überhaupt nicht vorstellen, wie Bukka das gewinnen will. Also wenn dann auch nur so dreckig ins Elfmeterschießen.
Ja, da hätten sie aber gewonnen, weil so sind sie ja doch in jeder Runde, der K.o.-Runde weitergekommen.
Genau, das muss man mal sehen, die haben ja auch kein einziges Spiel geronnen. Kein einziges K.o.-Spiel geronnen, wenn man mal sieht. Alvin Kula vier Tore, danach kommt Weigern zwei Tore, die spielen die gleiche Position, das sind Rechtsverteidiger. Die haben ja keine Stürmer-Tore, obwohl sie Cavani haben, der natürlich auch weit über seinen Zenit drüber ist. Benedetto ebenso, aber die haben halt auch nicht viele Schossen. Auch im Finale, da ist ja eigentlich, wenn ich jetzt mal davon absehe, da hieß es zwei Balleroberungen mit dem schnellen Umschaltspiel, was ja ihre Taktik war in der ersten Halbzeit. Einmal war es dann ein Fernschuss von Merenziello und das andere, diese, sag ich jetzt mal, verstolperte, verpasste Chance, Riesenschance eigentlich von Cavani. Danach kam ja nichts mehr. Und die Brasilianer hatten ja jetzt auch nicht massig Schossen, aber spielten halt diese Überlagerungen, dass der links außen auf die rechte Seite rübergeht, so wie vorm 1-0 beispielsweise, wo dann aber auch katastrophal verteidigt war, wiederum auch von Fabra, von Barco, von Valentini, von Adwinkula. Also so viele Fehler beim zweiten Tor, Figal, die ganze Viererkette bei Bukka patzt. Und ich weiß nicht, es war irgendwie ein unschönes Finale, fand ich, obwohl es natürlich spannend war. Aber ich fand, Fluminense hatte im Turnierverlauf gegen beispielsweise Argentinos Juniors von Gabi Milito im Achtelfinale viel mehr Probleme gehabt. Gegen International, das war auch eine ganz knappe Nummer gewesen im Halbfinale. Und weiß ich nicht, dass man gegen Bukka gewinnt und auch so wie es gelaufen ist, auch wenn es jetzt nicht superklar war. Aber das fand ich irgendwie schade.
Kann das vielleicht auch damit zusammenhängen, dass wir relativ viele Verletzungen gesehen haben? Also immer wieder mussten Spieler verletzt runter. Philipp Melo in der 52. Minute, Cavani nach 78 Minuten, Marcello nach 80 Minuten. Ich glaube, über alle drei werden wir auch gleich nochmal sprechen müssen. Und gleichzeitig gab es eben die Situation, also Bukka hatte absolut wenig Ballbesitz. Nach 14 Minuten waren es 13 Prozent, hatten 21 Pässe gespielt bis dahin. Aber Bukka hatte ja auch diese zwei Chancen nach Umschaltspiel. Und ich hatte das Gefühl, ich weiß nicht Johannes, ob es dir ähnlich ging, dass dieser Dinizismo, also eben, dass man auch die durchaus die Positionen mal aufgibt und eher so sich um den Ball herumgruppiert und dann sich so, ich würde mal fast so sagen, so ein Rondo bewegt sich über das Spielfeld hinweg und zockt sich einfach quasi so durch. Ich fand, das war relativ zurückhaltend gespielt. Und gerade in der letzten Kette, die Viererkette, die hat eigentlich Fluminense immer halbwegs in Formation behalten, weil ich eben glaube, man wusste ja, wie Bocca spielen wird. So haben sie die ganze K.o.-Runde durchgespielt. Und dass es auch daher kam, dass es deswegen ein zähes Finale war. Einmal, dass sich Fluminense ein bisschen zurückgenommen hat, weil man wusste, nur so kann Bocca wahrscheinlich Tore schießen, wenn wir irgendwie zu offen stehen. Und das Zweite eben, ja allein in der zweiten Hälfte, drei verletzungsbedingte Wechsel.
Ja, du sagst es, also es ist ein Finalspiel, da kannst du, man kann es schon sehr offensiv gestalten, aber eine etwas konservativere Spielweise ist da sicher das, was vorgegeben war. Beim Positionsspiel ist es bei Diniz, bei Fluminense eigentlich so, dass du vier Spieler hast, die die Position im Grunde halten, die sich tatsächlich nur in ihrem Positionsradius größtenteils bewegen. Das ist natürlich einmal der Torwart. Das sind in der Regel die zwei Innenverteidiger und das ist ganz vorne Jermán Cano und der Rest, also auch die Außenverteidiger, das sieht man in der Liga immer wieder, schieben auch mal in den gegnerischen Sechzehner in die Mitte, wie auch immer. Und ich finde, dass das im Finale eben konservativer war, dass auch die Außenverteidiger da mehr die Position gehalten haben und das Spiel, das eigentliche Spiel von Fluminense vielleicht so ein bisschen gehemmt, klingt jetzt ein bisschen hart, aber vielleicht hat sich da Fluminense nicht so ganz zur Entfaltung kommen lassen, wie sie das vielleicht sonst tun. Aber es ist halt einfach einem Finalspiel geschuldet, würde ich sagen. Das ist auch nicht unbedingt der falsche Ansatz, weil mal abgesehen vom WM-Finale letztes Jahr sind die meisten Finalspiele, da fallen doch nicht mehr als in der regulären Spielzeit mehr als zwei Tore. Das gibt es eigentlich eher selten und das ist, denke ich, auch dem geschuldet. Die Verletzungen werden sicherlich auch einen Einfluss gehabt haben. Bei Fluminenses Innenverteidiger war es ohnehin von vorne herein oder im Vorfeld ganz schwer zu beurteilen, wer da jetzt überhaupt beginnt, weil Philippe Mäler und Nino haben die letzten Spiele nicht gemacht. Die waren beide verletzt. Klar, standen dann beide im Kader, der ein paar Tage vorher bekannt gegeben wurde, aber es war nicht klar, ob die zwei jetzt spielen. Dann Manuel, ein dritter Innenverteidiger, der wurde gesperrt wegen Doping. Dann hat man noch Marlon, der von Schachter ausgeliehen ist. Mit dem habe ich eigentlich in der Startelf gerechnet, wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin, weil die zwei Verteidiger, die da gespielt haben, zuletzt nicht gespielt haben. Dann hast du noch David Braas, ein ganz alter Mann, der dann…
Da müssen wir gleich noch drüber sprechen. Aber ja.
Das ist wahr. Aber der springt dann auch nur meistens ein, wenn wirklich Not am Mann ist. Deswegen glaube ich, dass die Verletzung nicht ganz so unerwartet kam bzw. nicht ganz so viele Probleme gemacht haben, weil die nicht sowieso von vorne rein, sehr flexibel mit dem umgehen musste, mit den Spielern, die er zur Verfügung hatte.
Ja, lass uns mal kurz über das Alter der Fluminense-Spieler sprechen. Wenn wir jetzt gerade schon bei David Brass sind. Also der kam in der 103. Minute, der ist 36 Jahre alt und ist damit nur der dritte älteste, der auf dem Feld stand. Fabio 43 Jahre, Melo 40 Jahre, Brass dann eben 36, Marcello und Cano 35, Ganso und Keno 34. Und dann habe ich aufgehört aufzuschreiben, das Durchschnittsalter der Startelf 32,2 Jahre. Warum, Andreas, ist Fluminense ein Club der alten Männer?
Na ja, es sind halt auch einige Stars dabei, die muss man wirklich auch erstmal leisten können. Eine argentinische Mannschaft kann das nicht, sage ich jetzt mal, oder will das vielleicht auch nicht. Aber Brasilien ist halt schon normal, also rein ökonomisch eine andere Hausnummer. Da ist schon mindestens ein Klassenunterschied. Und dann hast du halt mal so eine All-Star-Truppe. Das finde ich auch erstmal gar nicht so schlimm, weil in Europa haben wir diesen starken Hype auf junge Talente, die man noch irgendwie entwickeln kann. Und das hast du natürlich in Südamerika erstmal so nicht. Wenn du eine junge Mannschaft in Südamerika hast, dann bist du ein Verkäufer. Da willst du Talente fördern und die teuer verkaufen. Die Mannschaften, die Titel holen in Südamerika, das sind meistens Routiniers. Und ich sage mal so, das hört sich vielleicht komisch an, aber Marcelo sagt zum Beispiel, das ist der größte Titel meiner Karriere. Ein Typ wie er, der alles gewonnen hat. Da herrscht nochmal, wenn man dann tatsächlich –du spielst in Rio Fußball. Und dann kommt mit Bucca vielleicht einer der größten possible Rivalen, die du haben kannst. Und zusammen mit einer argentinischen Mannschaft, das ist dann Bucca, der River, spielt jetzt erstmal keine Rolle. Da ist wahnsinnig Dampf auf dem Kessel. Wahnsinnig. Da kannst du natürlich so ein abgefuckter Hund sein, wie Kennedy, dem das scheißegal ist, der denen das sogar pusht. Aber viele Youngstars müssen auch mit diesem Druck und auch mit diesem medialen Chaos, der dann herrscht, um das Finale auch mal klarkommen. Da finde ich das gar nicht so verkehrt, wenn du so eine Mannschaft hast, die einfach abgewichst ist. Und wenn du die Spieler mal durchgehst bei Fluminense, das sind halt auch richtige Zocker dabei. Und wenn du dann stellst du die Mannschaft von Bucca, die ist nicht schlecht, die Mannschaft von Bucca, aber die hat natürlich viel weniger Fame, viel weniger Glanz und ist halt auch technisch viel schlechter. So und danach, ob sich dann der ein oder andere, klar, wenn du 40 oder Mitte 30, 40 spielst in den Finale, das war ja auch gerade Zweite Halbzeit Abnutzungskampf. Da sind die, wie die fliegen, so langsam in die Knie gegangen, so gerade bei Fluminense. Das war ja auch so ein bisschen zu erwarten. Aber an sich, wie gesagt, nochmal darauf zurückzukommen, dass alte Spieler jetzt erst mal eingesetzt werden, das finde ich gar nicht schlimm. Das ist Top-Team Südamerika, das ist ganz normal.
Ich würde gern sagen zu Philippe Melo, wenn man dem ja beim Fußballspielen zusieht, natürlich hat der überhaupt keine Geschwindigkeit mehr und sicherlich noch ein paar andere Schwächen. Aber wenn man denen so ins Gesicht schaut, also ich hätte als Gegenspieler wahnsinnige Angst, irgendwie nur in seine Nähe zu kommen. Das ist ja wirklich ein richtiger Krieger, wenn man so will, der alles erlebt hat und sich komplett für seine Mannschaft hingebt. Also wenn du mit ihm zusammenspielst, ist das eigentlich ein Segen, auch dann gegen eine Mannschaft wie Burka und die Fans. Wenn du da so einen an deiner Seite hast, der dich immer pusht und einfach auch so eine latent-aggressive Ausstrahlung hat, gibt das in einer Mannschaft in einem Finalspiel glaube ich auch unheimlich viel zu Marcelo. Andy hat es schon gesagt, das ist ja ein weltklasse Spieler, wenn du den nicht aufstellst. Und dann hast du mit Ganze und Cano zwei Mitte-30-Jährige, die gerade glaube ich auf dem besten Niveau sind, was sie je hatten in ihrer ganzen Karriere. So ganz sogar als Riesentalent hat er damals mit Neymar beim FC Santos so ein bisschen gezaubert und kam mit viel Versprechen nach Europa, die er im Grunde nie halten kann. So ehrlich muss man sein. Und dass er sich jetzt unter Fernando Diniz, auch letztes Jahr war er sogar noch etwas stärker, im Finale war er jetzt ja auch nicht ganz so stark. Aber trotzdem ist das ein Spieler, der sich im Herbst seiner Karriere tatsächlich noch mal weiterentwickelt hat und noch mal einen neuen Fußball kennengelernt hat, zu dem er perfekt passt. Und wie Fernando Diniz Herrmann-Carno so hinbekommen hat, können wir, glaube ich, nur spekulieren. Das ist ja unfassbar, wie der trifft. Auch schon letztes Jahr war er übers Jahr gesehen. Habe jetzt leider keine genaue Statistik, aber weltweit in den Top Ten auf jeden Fall, von der Trefferanzahl her. Und dass du dann auf so Spieler nicht verzichtet bist, ist klar. Deswegen glaube ich, Fernando Diniz interessiert das dann auch nicht. Und zum Finale darf das auch nicht interessieren. Da musst du die beste Mannschaft spielen oder die Spieler, die du am besten im Finale gebrauchen kannst. Und dann hast du ja trotzdem mit Andrej Martinelli zwei Riesentalente im zentralen Mittelfeld. Also Andrej wird im Winter spätestens nächsten europäischen Sommer nach Europa wechseln. Und Martinelli wird dann seine Rolle einnehmen. Dann hast du noch einen Alexandre draußen, auch 20 Jahre, dieselbe Position im Prinzip, 6er, 8er im zentralen Mittelfeld. Weil das ist dann auch nicht ganz zu überraschen, weil Fernando Diniz, man mag es kaum glauben, ist auch jemand, der junge Spieler fördert. Also wo er vor zwei Jahren beim FC Santos war, dann hat er auch in der Libertadores gespielt und auch um der Liga. Und da war das Altersdurchschnitt mit Abstand das jüngste der gesamten brasilianischen Liga. Der FC Santos hat vielleicht noch mal eine bessere Akademie so verglichen mit Fluminense. Da kommt dann noch mehr hoch. Aber das erkennt Fernando Diniz dann auch und gibt dann auch jungen Spielern eine Chance. Jetzt war es halt so, dass da auf jeden Fall die älteren Spieler überwiegt haben, so zu sagen.
Noch mal kurz zu Jereman Cano, der ist ja auch Argentinier, der zwar seine Karriere nur die ersten Jahre in Argentinien gespielt hat und erst danach so richtig explodiert ist. Aber ich habe die Statistik von ihm. Er hat bei Fluminense 125 Spiele, 81 Tore. Da nochmal 10 Torvorlagen dazu. Das ist schon bärenstark. Er hat jetzt 13 Tore geschossen, in der Libertadores, in zwölf Spielen und es gibt nur drei Spieler. Das ist Onega 66, Luisao 2000, Rafa 67, die überhaupt jemals mehr Tore geschossen haben in der Libertadores. Und da merkt man allein schon, was das für eine wahnsinnige Leistung von ihm war. Und wenn du da nochmal siehst, ich meine, er hat ja ab dem Viertelfinale in jedem Spiel getroffen. Da schießt Fluminense 11 Tore und er ist an neun beteiligt. Sieben macht er selbst, zwei bereitet davor. Und da waren ja teilweise, das sind ja auch meistens auch schöne Tore. Also das ist ein richtiger Killer. Und wird natürlich auch, das ist aber vor allem ein perfektes Ensemble da vorne drin bei Fluminense. Und da wird jeder Gegner, geht da so ein bisschen in die Knie. Und eigentlich, sagen wir mal so, du musst, und das hätte Boca machen müssen, aber die haben ja die Spieler nicht und sind es auch nicht gewohnt, so wie Gaby Milito hat spielen lassen gegen Fluminense, dieses hohe Pressing, aber mit schnellen, auch jüngeren Spielern. Da haben die dann immer Probleme bekommen. Das hat man an mehreren Stellen gesehen in den beiden Achtelfinalspielen. Und auch da war es ja so, dass dann zwei Sonntagsschüsse, vor allem im Hinspiel, beide auch kurz vor Schluss, Fluminense so ein bisschen gerettet haben. Und du wirst dieser Mannschaft halt, wenn du mitspielst, dann wirst du da kaum beikommen, weil die viel zu stark ist. Und vor allem mit so einem Goalgetter gesegnet ist. Und davon gibt es ja, sind wir mal ehrlich, da haben wir in Europa nicht viele, da haben wir in Südamerika auch nicht so viele. Wenn du so jemanden hast, der dir einfach ein Tor gerannt ist, dann bist du titelreif. Und das war halt so.
Und es schien ja offenbar so sein zu müssen. Philippe Melo, du hast das gesagt, Johannes, man will nicht gegen ihn spielen, so ein harter Hund. Außer er gibt dann das Interview nach dem Sieg eben in der Copa. Dann heult er wie ein Schlosshund und ist ganz weich. Genauso ja mit Marcelo. Das war ja auch das, was, glaube ich, in den europäischen Medien am meisten berichtet wurde. Marcelo, der eben mit Real Madrid alles gewonnen hat, was man gewinnen kann und dann sagt, Real wird es mir verzeihen, alle Fans werden mir verzeihen. Das ist der wichtigste Titel meiner Karriere, weil es eben sein Heimatverein ist, zu dem er zurückgekehrt ist. Das waren, glaube ich, so die Schlagzeilen, die hier angekommen sind. Und eben darüber hinaus gar nicht mehr so viel, fand ich. Also über die Ausschreitungen vor dem Spiel. Also es gab einen Angriff, kann man das so sagen, von Fluminense-Fans auf Boca-Fans am Strand von Rio de Janeiro. Das ist noch in den Medien aufgetaucht. Aber arg viel mehr war es dann gar nicht mehr so. Deswegen finde ich es schön, dass wir das jetzt anreichern konnten. Ich weiß nicht, sollten wir darüber noch kurz ein paar Worte verlieren? Hatte das eine besondere Qualität? Andreas, du hast was gesagt mit, dass es Probleme mit der argentinischen Polizei gab. Das habe ich jetzt dann wiederum gar nicht mitbekommen. Das wäre ein bisschen komisch, wenn es die argentinische Polizei gewesen wäre. Die haben ihre Polizei mitgebracht. Das war dann das Problem. Gibt es dazu etwas zu sagen? Hatte das eine besondere Qualität?
Ich würde sagen, das sind die normalen Nebengeräusche, die bei so einem Spiel immer passieren. Gerade wenn Argentinien und Brasilien aufeinandertrifft. Ganz normaler Wahnsinn.
Ich glaube, das Besondere tatsächlich so absurd, das klingt an diesen Ausstreitungen, war, dass diese Setting an der Copacabana, dass die 150 Fluminense-Fans da den Strand quasi stürmen und auf die Burka-Fans laufen. Es gab auch ein, zwei Schlägereien, aber es ist nichts sehr Schlimmes passiert zum Glück. Ich glaube, das sollte nicht über den Wettbewerb, über das Finale und so weiter hinweg, es sollte nicht darüber stehen. Es gab dann eigentlich danach, glaube ich, wurden von keinen größeren Ausschreitungen mehr berichtet. Was dann eher bleiben sollte, sind diese fantastischen Bilder, wo die Burka-Fans an der Copacabana feiern mit diesen blau-gelben Pyros. Dann gibt es wunderbare Drohnenaufnahmen, wie alle einfach friedlich feiern und eine gute Zeit haben. Das ist sehr schön anzusehen.
So wie auch viele Szenen sehr schön anzusehen waren. Ich hätte auch nie gedacht, dass ich noch mal ein Nasenpflaster in Aktion sehe. Abim Hula, der Tor-Schützer. Kein Wunder, dass er getroffen hat. In der großen Tradition Harry Kochs hat er mit Nasenpflaster getroffen. Und Olaf Marschals hat er getroffen. Ach, es war auch tolle Übertragung. Sofetzer hat es bei Sport1 Plus kommentiert. Ein rundes Ergebnis. Und wie ihr ja jetzt auch ganz schön rausgearbeitet habt, dann vermutlich mit dem verdienten Sieger. Zumindest wenn man jetzt nicht Hardcore-Bokka-Fan ist, muss man sagen, die sportliche Leistung von Fluminense, die war eben einfach sehr, sehr gut in diesem Turnier. Und das weitet ja dann schon so ein bisschen den Blick. Dann lass doch mal so allgemein über diesen Wettbewerb sprechen. Andreas, wer waren denn so für dich die Überraschungen in dieser Copa-Ausgabe?
Naja, so große Überraschungen gab es eigentlich dieses Mal nicht. Es gab schon einige Teams, die so ein bisschen überperformed haben und andere natürlich unterperformed haben. Also so eine Mannschaft, die mir halt gefällt, war Argentinos Juniors, weil ich einfach finde, dass Gaby Milito einer der besten Trainern Südamerika ist und der aus Mannschaften das Maximale rausholt. Diese Truppen von ihm sind total schwer zu spielen und trotzdem aber attraktiv anzuschauen. Also jetzt nicht nur destruktiver Fußball. Das ist schon, man merkt halt einfach seine Erfahrungen im europäischen Fußball und das tut so einer Außenseiter-Truppe sehr gut. Danach, ich finde, man kann sich immer intervenieren. Del Valle kann man sich immer schön aus das Ecuador. Das ist eigentlich auch so, sagen wir mal, zweite Kategorie. Die kann man sich auch immer ganz gut anschauen. Aber alles in allem, man muss trotzdem sagen, man hat so eine Handvoll brasilianische Teams. Das ist jetzt Fluminense gewesen. Ich nehme jetzt mal noch Palmeiras dazu und Flamengo. Und man kann natürlich über International, die haben mir auch gefallen. Die musst du einfach benennen. Das sind die Referenzen. Und im Normalfall, die einzige Mannschaft, die da, außerhalb von Brasilien, die da was reißen kann, ist River Plate. Ich fand die auch nicht schlecht. Die haben das Problem, dass sie auswärts unter dem Michaelis überhaupt nicht zünden. Dass sie da halt einfach unterperformen, ständig. Und dass es ihnen dann auf die Füße gefallen in dem K.o.-Spiel, in dem Rückspiel. Aber da reden wir später nochmal. Für mich war das das beste Spiel auch, dieses Rückspiel. Aber ansonsten, wer hat mir noch gefallen? Ja, ich fand Olympia hatte ein geiles Comeback hier am Achtelfinale, als sie zu Hause das 1-0 noch aufholen und noch drei Buden machen. Und das dritte Tor war auch noch von einem Ex-Kilmes, Argentino. War nicht schön, aber zu Hause ein 3-1 vor so einer verrückten Kulisse, das war noch eine positive Überraschung für mich. Aber generell war es spielerisch. Klar, man kann sagen, Club Bolivar mit dem baskischen Trainer, das ist so ein bisschen, die haben ihre Außenseiterrolle maximal ausgenutzt. Ja, aber ich weiß nicht, Jo, wie du das gesehen hast. Haben wir jetzt spielerisch, haben wir jetzt nicht wirklich, waren wir nicht gute Truppen gesehen?
Ja, würde ich grundsätzlich erstmal mit dir mitgehen. Also international fand ich auch eine positive Überraschung. Aber nochmal zu diesem Olympia, also das ist natürlich aus Asuncion keine riesen Spielkultur, die die da auf den Platz bringen. Aber ich finde tatsächlich, das ist eine der größten Überraschungen der letzten vier, fünf Jahre der Libertadores, dass die im Achtelfinale Flamengo rausgehauen haben. Also die nach der Auslosung, die die Fans von Flamengo haben in den sozialen Medien komplett gefeiert, dass sie schon im Viertelfinale stehen. Flamengo hat im südamerikanischen Sommer, also im letzten Januar, mit Gerson den teuersten Transfer überhaupt in Südamerika getätigt. Als er da zurückkommt, haben unfassbar starken Kader, sind jedes Jahr der absolute Topfavorit mit den Vereinen, die Andi genannt hat, auf die Libertadores und dass sie dann im Hinspiel 1-0 gewinnen und das dann noch mit einem 3 zu 1 gegen eine Mannschaft, die keine Stars hat, die in der Liga zu dem Zeitpunkt tatsächlich auch, ich glaube, 3-mal hintereinander verloren hatte oder irgendwie sowas, was für Olympia eine absolute Katastrophe ist, weil die Liga in Paraguay eben bis auf Olympia Cerro und Libertad relativ schwach ist, also da gibt es diese drei Top-Vereine, die quasi die Meisterschaft immer unter sich ausmachen und da haben sie überhaupt nicht performt und dann gegen eine der besten Mannschaften des Kontinents 3 zu 1 gewinnen, wie gesagt, mit keinen großen spielerischen Mitteln. Alle Tore waren Kopfballtreffer, alle drei. Das hat mir großen Spaß gemacht, das fand ich fantastisch. Ich mag Flamengo, aber da war ich überhaupt nicht traurig über das Ausscheiden. Ich habe dieses Jahr tatsächlich nicht so viele Spiele live geschaut, leider. Das ist ja auch immer nicht ganz einfach mit den Uhrzeiten. Aber das Rückspiel im Viertelfinale gegen Fluminense habe ich mir dann von Olympia angeguckt, weil mich das dann doch begeistert hat, wie die so einen Riesenfavoriten rausgekickt haben. Dann habe ich so ein bisschen gehofft, dass das vielleicht nochmal passiert. Da waren dann komplett Chancen los gegen Fluminense. So ehrlich muss man dann sein. Aber das ist mir wirklich hängen geblieben, wenn man von Überraschungen spricht.
Spielt ihr das eine große Rolle, dass hier verschiedene Ligen und verschiedene Länder gegeneinander antreten? Ich glaube, wir müssen gleich nochmal über die brasilianische Dominanz gerade sprechen und woher das kommt. Aber weil du jetzt eben gesagt hast, Olympia ist ja eben ein Team aus Paraguay. Ist das etwas, was wichtig ist, wenn man diesen Wettbewerb verfolgt, also eben quasi für die Fans vor Ort wichtig ist, Andreas?
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, ob ich die Frage richtig verstanden habe. Formule mal bitte um. Ich weiß nicht genau, was du hier hinaus wolltest.
Hier geht es ja immer darum, jetzt auf den europäischen Fußball gesehen, wie schneidet die Premier League ab, wie schneidet La Liga ab usw. Und haben irgendwelche anderen die Chance, in diese Farlangs reinzukommen. Ist das im Grunde, kann man das so übertragen auf die Copa?
Ja, im Grunde, du hast Argentinien, du hast Brasilien und dann hast du, ich sag's mal, danach kommt nichts. Danach kommt nichts. Wenn dann überhaupt, dann hast du, ich meine, ich glaube alle anderen Länder zusammen haben ja nur nicht mal 10 Titel oder kommen auf vielleicht 10. Währenddessen Argentinien irgendwie 28, Brasilien 25, irgendwie sowas, Libertadores Sieger hat und letztendlich du hast da deine Handvoll brasilianischer, argentinischer Top-Vereine und alle anderen sind erstmal Außenseiter. Und natürlich, wenn du dann so eine Flamengus zusammen mit Palmeiras, die beste Mannschaft der letzten 5 Jahre, wenn du dann als Olympia so eine Truppe zu Hause 3-1 wegputzt, das ist ja explodiert, das Stadion. Das waren ja wunderbare Bilder, so zu sehen in die Fan-Kurve, wie die abgegangen sind. Weil sie halt wissen, das ist nicht normal. Und die Schere ist schon normal weiter auseinander als jetzt hier in Europa. Das muss man schon so sehen. Es ist eigentlich dann eher so, dass die Copa Südamerikaner, also sowas wie die Europa League, dass die offener ist für andere Länder, sage ich jetzt mal, außerhalb von Brasilien und Argentinien. Aber die Libertadores, wenn die Brasilianer und Argentiner nicht schwächeln, dann geht das immer in einen der beiden Länder. Da kannst du wetten drauf eigentlich.
Und woher kommt das, Johannes, das jetzt dann in den letzten Jahren, ich glaube 2018 war doch der letzte argentinische Sieger und seitdem nur brasilianische Teams, wenn ich mich gerade richtig erinnere. Woher kommt das? Ist das das ökonomische Ungleichgewicht, was Andreas gerade schon angesprochen hat?
Das ist der Hauptgrund, würde ich sagen. Zum einen, weil Brasilien vermarktungstechnisch sehr, sehr viel richtig macht. Sie haben ein klares Liegensystem, das seit fast 20 Jahren jetzt, das sich genau nach dem europäischen Muster orientiert. Also ganz früher gab es ja immer Abwehrtoder und Klausucher, also Hinrundenmeisterschaft, Rückrundenmeisterschaft. Das ist nicht so greifbar in Europa eigentlich. Es gibt es ja auch noch heutzutage im Paraguay beispielsweise oder Uruguay. Aber die haben das da schon mal umgestellt. Dann haben sie riesen Fernsehdeals bekommen mit ESPN, mit chinesischen Übertragungssendern. Und haben dann auch noch für die Vereine das Sponsoring ein bisschen geöffnet. Beispielsweise Palmeiras kriegt jährlich, ich kenne die Zahlen jetzt nicht genau, aber von Crefisa, das ist eine riesen Bank, werden die einfach zugebuttert mit Geld. Das sind halt riesen Beträge. Dann, man kennt das, die Brasilianer, die nach Europa wechseln, wechseln dann auch nochmal für ganz andere Preise als jetzt aus anderen Ländern auch, andere Preise als aus Argentinien. Und das spielt alles so ein bisschen zusammen. Und gleichzeitig, da kann Andi sicherlich noch ein bisschen mehr erzählen, muss man auch sehen, dass Argentinien genau das, was Brasilien richtig macht, einfach komplett falsch macht. Also die Liga hat ja 28 Teams, die zweite Liga hat 37 Teams. Also nur in den ersten zwei Ligen. Dann wurde jetzt während der Saison irgendwie so halb beschlossen, dass jetzt doch nur noch eine Mannschaft absteigt und dafür drei hochkommen. Nächstes Jahr wird es wohl 30 Teams in der ersten Liga geben. Dann gibt es halt eine Meisterschaft, wo jeder einmal gegen einen spielt. Das ist sozusagen die reguläre Meisterschaft. Und dann gibt es jetzt seit zwei, drei Jahren in der zweiten Saisonphase die Copa de la Liga, wo dann sich die Liga spaltet in zwei Gruppen. Und dann spielen sie da gegeneinander. Und dann gibt es die ersten vier gehen ins Viertelfinal. Also es ist so ein bisschen einfach verkompliziert und nicht so gradlinig. Und das macht es einfach unattraktiver. Ja, vermarktungstechnisch einfach gesehen. Das muss man so sagen. Wir wissen alle, wie viel Geld in TV-Rechten steckt. Das ist ja absurd. Und das sind so ein bisschen die Eckpunkte zumindest, was eben diesen großen finanziellen Unterschied macht. Jetzt Brasilien und Argentinien im Vergleich, aber natürlich auch Brasilien und Argentinien im Vergleich zum Rest. Aber am Ende muss man natürlich auch sagen, dass die besten Spieler Südamerikas aus Brasilien und Argentinien kommen. Das ist natürlich auch der Hauptgrund, warum die Vereine so gut sind. Das sind ganz verschiedene Sachen.
Ich wollte da nochmal was ergänzen. Wenn jetzt eine Mannschaft aus Ecuador verkauft ihr Top-Talent, dann sagen wir mal, ich glaube, mehr als 5 Millionen ist eigentlich nicht drin. Eigentlich kannst du ein Faktor 3 nehmen. Eine argentinische Mannschaft verkauft ihr Top-Talent dreimal so teuer für 15 und eine brasilianische nochmal dreimal so teuer für 45. Das sind wahnsinnige Unterschiede. Und du hast auch schon, ich meine, ein argentinischer Profi, der verdient ja nur teilweise, es gibt Spieler in der 3. Liga in Deutschland, die verdienen mehr. Es gibt auch Spieler in der Regionalliga, die verdienen mehr als jemand, der in der 1. Liga spielt in Argentinien, kommt drauf an, bei welchem Verein und Stellenwert von dem einzelnen Spieler. Und in Brasilien verdienst du gut, das ist gutes Geld. Und ich sage mal so, für Argentinien, und dann gilt natürlich für die ganzen Paraguay-Shows, Uruguay-Shows, gilt natürlich genauso. Dieser Step nach Europa ist eine wahnsinnige Verbesserung. Wenn du bei einem, das sind ja mehrere starke, finanzstarke Teams in Brasilien, wenn du da spielst, dann hast du ein geiles Gehalt, du hast super Trainingsbedingungen, dein Trainerteam ist meistens doppelt so groß wie das vergleichsweise in Argentinien. Alles ist besser. Die Kultur ist natürlich dementsprechend auch eigentlich ganz, ganz geil zu leben. Brasilien ist auch nicht schlecht von der Lebensqualität her. Das ist wahnsinnig attraktiv, dieses Gesamtpaket. Und ich sage mal so, bleibt mal ein paar Argentinien. Argentinisches Top-Talent, das nicht relativ schnell von einem europäischen Club gekauft wird, geht entweder nach Brasilien oder in die MLS. Das sind Lichtjahre dazwischen. Und das, wenn man jetzt mal schaut –ich meine, wir haben jetzt Fluminense, Boca Juniors, Brasilien gegen Argentinien, die drei Jahre davor hatten, rein brasilianische Duelle im Finale. Das ist ja Wahnsinn. Ich glaube, das gab es noch nie, dass das so eindeutig war. Ich glaube nicht, dass sich das in den nächsten Jahren ändert. Weil, auch angesprochen von Jograt schon, Chiguita Pia, das muss man sich mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Es ist ja im Finale immer noch nicht geklärt. Geht jetzt einer runter, geht zwei runter, geht gar keiner runter, wurde ja auch diskutiert, geht gar keiner runter. Ich meine, es sind noch zwei Spieljahre, ne? Dann haben die zwei Ligen pro Jahr. Die eine ist die Copa de la Liga, was hier irgendwie so ein Ligapokal ist, und dann die Liga. Das heißt, die spielen zwei Wettbewerbe, die auch noch zwei verschiedene Namen haben. Also zwei verschiedene Formate, zwei verschiedene Namen. Und das ist ein riesiges Chaos auf dieser AFA-Ebene. Und wie man Turniere plant und organisiert. Dem argentinischen Verband. Das ist ja als Zuschauer zum Beispiel. Ich interessiere mich jetzt gerade bei der Copa, die jetzt aktuell gespielt wird, interessiere ich mich nur für den Abstiegskampf, weil dieser, sagen wir so, der Titel, der ist nicht, auch in Argentinien, der ist nicht besonders hochdekoriert, der ist nicht so wichtig. Aber was wichtiger ist, wer absteigt. Und da sind natürlich auch einige Traditionsmannschaften mitten im Abstiegskampf. Und dann hast du halt einen Verbandschef, der das alles killen will von heute auf morgen. Und das ist ja natürlich für die Außenwirkung und für die Attraktivität der Liga, ist das eine Vollkatastrophe einfach mal. Und wissen wir alle selbst, die Brasilianer, ich weiß nicht, wie 20, 22 Teams in ihrer Liga, ich glaube 20, was redet, gerade kann ich es so genau, im Vergleich zu irgendwie dem Nachbar, der jetzt fast auf die 30 kommt, ja, das tut nicht gut. Das braucht keine Liga, sowas. Und das in the long run, spiegelt sich das natürlich dann halt in der Wettbewerbsfähigkeit auch wieder.
Und machen da auch die grundsätzlichen ökonomischen Unterschiede zwischen den beiden Ländern noch einen weiteren Unterschied? Oder spielt da der Fußball so eine Sonderrolle, dass man das jetzt nicht nennen kann? Weil vom Bruttoinlandsprodukt, ich meine, ich weiß, es ist schwierig, das jetzt nur als Kennzahl herzunehmen. Also Russland hat gerade einen super BIP, das ist, weil sie alles in Rüstung stecken. Ob damit jetzt wirklich was für die Wirtschaft gemacht ist, kann man diskutieren. Aber mit dieser Klammer da außenrum, da sieht man Brasilien 2022 bei 1,9 Milliarden US-Dollar und Argentinien fast die Hälfte, 630 Millionen. Das ist der Unterschied. Also Argentinien ungefähr auf einer Ebene mit Polen und Brasilien ungefähr auf einer Ebene mit Australien, Italien, da ist man so ein bisschen so im Sandwich. Also da gibt es schon deutlich einen Unterschied. Und ich meine, über Inflation in Argentinien könnte man ja jetzt ganze Stunden sprechen. Das ist ja dramatisch, was da zum Teil passiert ist in den letzten Jahren. Aber spielt es dann auch wirklich im Fußball eine große Rolle, der trotzdem ja immer viel Geld reinholt? Weil es ist ja Fußball, ich weiß nicht, Andreas?
Sicherlich. Also klar, das ist so. Aber es wäre jetzt einfach, sich darauf auszuruhen. Weil es gibt ja auch, das sind eher strategische Probleme. Weiß ich nicht. Boca hat ja Geld. Und die schaffen es trotzdem nicht, jetzt seit mehreren Jahren eine halbwegs gute Truppe auf internationalem Niveau zusammenzustellen, auf den Platz zu bringen. Auch wenn sie jetzt im Finale waren. Aber da waren wir uns ja einig, dass das eher ein Unfall war. Als irgendwas anderes. Das hilft natürlich, wenn mehr Geld da ist. Aber die Struktur ist auch anders in den Vereinen. Es fließt bei weitem mehr Geld irgendwie von außen in diese Clubs rein. Und du hast natürlich einfach auch –ich meine, Brasilien ist ein riesiges Land. So viel größer, so viel mehr Einwohner. Und du hast einfach in Brasilien ein fußballerisches Potenzial. Das ist das Beste der Welt. Das müssen wir mal –das können wir ja mal einfach so sagen. Ich meine, selbst als stolze Fußballnation, die wir selbst sind, keiner kann es mit den Brasilianern aufnehmen.
Moment mal, willst du etwa sagen, der deutsche Nachwuchs ist dem brasilianischen Nachwuchs unterlegen? Das kann doch gar nicht sein. Wir haben doch die DFB-Stützpunkte.
Hä?
Checkt das nicht.
Würde ich nie sagen. Am Ende des Tages, Geld schießt ein paar Tore, nicht alle. Aber Brasilien ist da einfach besser aufgestellt in allen Belangen. Das hat zum Ergebnis, dass wir nur noch brasilianische Titelträger haben. Und das erst mal auch so bleiben wird.
Na schön, dann haben wir ja die nächsten Jahre auch schon abgefrühstückt. Aber dann lasst uns nochmal zu den sportlichen Dingen zurückkommen. Die besten Spiele dieses Turniers wollte ich gerne von euch hören. Andreas hat vorhin schon einen Hinweis gegeben, worüber er noch sprechen müsste. Deswegen bekommt jetzt Johannes die Möglichkeit vorzulegen. Was waren denn so Partien, die in Erinnerung bleiben werden? Natürlich das Finale, aber darüber hinaus noch.
In der Gruppenphase waren das sicherlich die beiden Duelle von Fluminense und Riva. Fluminense hat Riva 5 zu 1 zu Hause abgeschossen. Andi hat eben schon die Auswärtsschwäche von Riva angesprochen, aber dass es dann so deutlich wird, das war eine Riesenüberraschung. Das war, glaube ich, eine der höchsten Niederlagen von Riva in der Libertadores. Und dann im Umkehrschluss aber dieses Rückspiel, wo Riva es dann gut gemacht hat mit einem 2 zu 0. Das waren ganz geile Partien. Im Achtelfinale gab es noch eine ganz wilde Partie. Die habe ich mir auch vorhin noch mal, zumindest die Highlights, noch mal kurz angeschaut. Das war Atletico Nacional aus Kolumbien gegen Racing. Die haben 4 zu 2 gewonnen, Atletico Nacional. Man muss sagen, dass früher, vielleicht vor zehn Jahren, das Standing der Ligen eben so war, dass du hast Brasilien und Argentinien, dann lange nix und dann Kolumbien, so ungefähr. Das hat sich in den letzten Jahren meiner Meinung nach auch ein bisschen aufgelöst. Da ist Ecuador einfach vorbeigezogen an den Kolumbianern, die halt auch oft in der Libertadores enttäuscht haben, dann auch schon teilweise die Top-Teams in der Qualifikation scheitern und so weiter. Und ich meine, das war so eine Leistung, dieses 4 zu 2, wo sie Atletico Nacional unfassbaren Fußball gespielt haben, richtig schöne Tore erzielt haben, um dann mit diesem 4 zu 2 Sieg nach Avellaneda zu reisen, nach Argentinien, und 3 zu 0 abgeschossen zu werden mit der wahrscheinlich schlechtesten Leistung des ganzen Achtelfinales. Absolute Gegensätze, ich weiß nicht genau, wahrscheinlich lag da zwei, maximal drei Wochen zwischen diesen beiden Spielen. Absolut unverständlich, aber natürlich auch dieser Heimvorteil in Südamerika ist auch nochmal, glaube ich, nochmal ganz anders als in Europa, wie die Vereine agieren zuhause und auswärts und was dann natürlich für eine Atmosphäre herrscht in den Stadion bei diesen Spielen absolut verrückt. Und das war so ein Achtelfinale, was am Ende beide Mannschaften, also Atletico ist dann ausgeschieden, Racing dann eine Runde später gegen Boca, also zwei Teams, die jetzt nicht so erfolgreich waren in der Libertadores, aber sich so ein geiles Achtelfinale da geliefert haben, das hat schon richtig Bock gemacht. Das sind so, ja, also das River Fluminense und Atletico-National-Racing-Ding, das waren zwei coole Duelle.
Ja, bis zur 82. Minute stand es bei diesem 4-2 im Hinspiel noch 2-0 und dann ging es los. 3-0, 3-1, 3-2 und dann noch 4-2 in der Nachspielzeit. Gibt es denn die Auswärtssor-Regel in der Copa noch? Obwohl es da doch eine Rolle spielt, so wie ich gerade von dir gelernt habe. Naja, muss man alles den Europäern nachmachen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das in dem Fall dann etwas Gutes ist. Andreas, du hast vorhin schon kurz eingedeutet, was waren für dich die besten Spiele dieses Turniers?
Ja, in der Gruppenphase gehe ich das 5-1. Das ist halt das, daran erinnert man sich. Das war halt auch spektakulär einfach nur. Ich habe es jetzt auch schon lange nicht mehr gesehen, dass Riva dermaßen auseinandergenommen wurde. Auch wenn das Ergebnis jetzt –so schlecht war Riva gar nicht. Aber trotzdem, man muss erst mal fünf Buden machen. Also kann ich mich jetzt auch wirklich nicht erinnern, wann das letztes Mal passiert ist, dass die so viel geschluckt haben. Aber was für mich, vor allem weil es halt einfach kurios ohne Ende war, war schon dieses Rückspiel in Porto Alegre international gegen Riva Plate. Nachdem Riva zu Hause ziemlich souverän erst mal vorgelegt hat mit einem Tor, 2-1 gewonnen. Und dann im Rückspiel dann ist Gaby Mercado, man kennt ihn vielleicht aus Sevilla, war auch Nationalspieler, also eigentlich auch so ein Arbeitertyp, eigentlich jetzt fußballerisch eher so limitiert. Und mittlerweile, früher Rechtsverteidiger, mal rechtes Mittelfeld, mal Innenverteidiger, jetzt so noch Innenverteidiger. Und knallt da so ein Kopfball rein und gleicht die Serie aus. Man muss dazu wissen, Gaby Maccardo hat mit River alles gewonnen. Er war vier Jahre da, Südamerikaner, Libertadores, Meistertitel, alles da und der knallt das Ding da rein.
Also ausgerechnet er macht das.
Ausgerechnet er, gleicht die Serie aus. Danach legen sie noch mal einen drauf, dann steht es 2-0. Und River kommt halt auch mit so ein bisschen Kuriosen, so halb gegrätscht, halb artistisch, auch wieder von einem Verteidiger, von Rojas, macht dann in der Neunzigsten das 2-1 und dementsprechend ging es natürlich dann ins Elfmeterschießen. Und dann gab es halt irgendwie zehn Schützen pro Seite. Und auch wie so kurios Pablo Solari im Hinspiel noch Doppeltorschütze tritt halt an und rutscht aus, berührt so ganz leicht mit dem rutschenden Standfuß. Man konnte es echt schwer sehen. Ich habe es mir auch oftmals angucken müssen.
Also unerlaubter Doppelkontakt.
Der Florian Kainz. Genau das war es. Hat dann nicht gezählt. Und bei der ganzen Aktion hat er halt auch noch den Elfmeterpunkt so total zerstört. Wurden dann noch ein paar Elfmeter geschossen. Solaris Elfmeter hat dann nicht gezählt. Der nächste schießt an den Pfosten oder so. Vorteil auch nicht ausgenutzt. Dann wurden noch mal zwei Schützen kamen, die noch mal getroffen haben. Dann wurde die Seite gewechselt, weil der Elfmeterpunkt so im Arsch war. Und dann kommt ausgerechnet Rojas, der in den Last-Minute-Ausgleich quasi geschossen hat. Und knallt das Ding gegen die Latte. Bei dem ersten Elfmeter auf die andere Seite. Und dann kommt Rojet, der Tormann, der Uruguay-Show. Und macht dann den entscheidenden Elfmeter rein. Das war so von, weiß ich nicht, da war vieles drin. Da war eigentlich alles drin, was du von so einem Libertadores-Spiel sehen wolltest. Und deswegen war das für mich so, das war partidazo. Das war geil.
Ey wirklich, das ist so, ich werde mir auf jeden Fall die Highlights vor diesem Spiel nochmal angucken. Du hast mich jetzt richtig heiß gemacht eigentlich. Hätten wir das während des Laufens im Wettbewerb machen müssen. Ach man, ich schaffe es immer nicht, noch mehr Sendungen einzuschieben, das ist richtig schade. Denn dann hätten wir auch schon mal über Shootingstars gesprochen. Also Spieler, die vielleicht nochmal woanders eine große Rolle spielen werden. Wir haben jetzt schon gelernt, warum für manche Vereine quasi der Endpunkt für Spielerkarrieren sind und deswegen auch ältere Spieler da spielen. Aber ja sogar in so einer Rentnertruppe, sage ich jetzt einfach mal, wie bei Fluminense, spielen ja auch junge Spieler. Kennedy ist ja zum Beispiel einer von ihnen. Johannes, wer sind denn so junge Spieler, auf die wir ein Auge werfen sollten? Du hast davor auch schon zwei Namen genannt, weil sie eben vielleicht auch mal im europäischen Fußball ankommen könnten.
Den, den du gerade genannt hast. Wir kommen nicht drum herum über John Kennedy. John Kennedy Batista de Souza. Also allein der Name ist ja Programm und komplett verrückt. Der Typ, der ist 21 und was der in seiner Karriere schon erlebt hat, das ist absurd. Also mal ganz davon abgesehen, dass er eine unfassbare Qualität hat, ist es auch, was er an Höhen und Tiefen auch oft sehr selbstverschuldet durchgemacht hat, ist das einfachen Typ. Ich hoffe, dass der sowas von dem Durchbruch schafft. Wenn man seine Qualitäten ansieht, ist er unfassbar sicher im 1 gegen 1, im Abschluss. Tollendes Tanzschuss, ist verdammt schnell, kann gut im Kombinationsspiel, sonst wird er nicht in einer Mannschaft von Fernando Dinis spielen. Das passt alles. Wir können vielleicht kurz auf die letzten zwei Jahre von dem Typen schauen. Er hat schon in seiner Jugend, das ist jetzt ein bisschen mehr als zwei Jahre, die Klubs sehr oft gewechselt, weil hier und da hat er sich mit einem Mitspieler angelegt. Dann wollte ein Trainer ihn mal umschulen zum Rechtsverteidiger. Das hat ihm nicht gepasst und ist dann von selbst gegangen. Das ist ein Typ, der kommt aus schweren Verhältnissen, aus einer Favela. Er hat viel gesehen in seinem Leben, zumindest so wie man hört, und hat dann schon relativ unterklassisch gespielt und auf so einem Turnier. Dieses Turnierscouting im Brasilien ist ja komplett ausgeprägt bei diesen Jugendturnieren. Das ist unglaublich, was da erstens geleistet wird und was da für Scouts überall in den letzten Provinzen rumlaufen, in diesem riesigen Land. Und da hat John Kennedy –ich glaube, es war in der U15, wenn ich mich nicht ganz irre, ich bin mir gerade nicht ganz sicher –hatte da ein Turnier alles auseinander geschossen und wurde dann nochmal von Fluminense verpflichtet. Dort hat es ihm gefallen, hat sich dann so ein bisschen gesettet. Dann vor zwei Jahren sein Debüt gegeben und kam so langsam rein. Und dann das Fla-Flu, also das Derby Flamengo gegen Fluminense, das ist so in Brasilien vielleicht das größte Derby. Da gibt es noch in São Paulo natürlich auch noch ein paar große Spiele. Aber das Fla-Flu ist sehr historisch und schießt mich stolz, wie viele Partien da in den letzten 100 Jahren absolviert wurden. Er ist eigentlich in dieser Saison dritter Stürmer. Fred, den kennen wir noch von der WM 2004, hat sich verletzt. Raúl Bobadilla, der auch zum Kader gehört hat, war auch verletzt. Und dann musste John Kenegy rein und hat in einem der größten Spiele für Fluminense –das habe ich tatsächlich auch live gesehen –und da ist mir zum ersten Mal so richtig aufgefallen. Das war im September 2021. Er hat einfach einen Doppelpack erzielt. Aus dem Nichts hat er dieses großartige Spiel mit fantastischen Toren entschieden. Dann, man kennt es, Riesenhype, Rieseneuphorie. Und dann der Absturz. Im Januar hat er nochmal in der Copinha gespielt. Das ist so das größte Jugendturnier in Brasilien, wo auch Enriqi alles auseinandergeschossen hat, wo diese ganzen Videos über den Stürmer kamen. Da hat John Kennedy auch mitgespielt, auch gut performt. Er ist dann irgendwie in eine Schlägerei geraten, und dann wurde es alles ein bisschen schwerer. Dann kam Fernando Diniz, da hat er noch ein paar Spiele gemacht, war dann disziplinlos, hatte Probleme mit der Polizei, weil er falschen Freunden sein Auto geliehen hat. All sowas, was ihn komplett rausgebracht hat, hat dann letztes Jahr nichts gerissen. Er wurde dann Anfang des Jahres nach Fedoravia verliehen. Die spielen in der vierten Liga. Für drei Monate wurde er verliehen, aber nicht für den Liga-Betrieb, sondern die Staatsmeisterschaft. Das war eine Staatsmeisterschaft von São Paulo, die immer vor der Saison, von Februar bis April, ausgetragen wird. Er hat dafür in den vierten Ligas fünf oder sechs Tore erzielt und kam dann zurück zu Fluminense, wieder zu Fernando Diniz. Dann hat es Fernando Diniz irgendwie geschafft, dem Jungen Disziplin beizubringen, zu schaffen, dass er in der Konstanz gut trainiert, gut spielt und in der K.o.-Phase hat er auch ein paar Mal getroffen, dass er es dann hinbekommt, regelmäßig sein Potenzial abzurufen. Ich hoffe, ich werde jetzt nicht zu ausschweifen, aber das ist einfach eine geile Geschichte, die der Typ hat. Dann hat Fernando Diniz damals auch gesagt, dass es in Brasilien sehr viele John-Kanegis gibt und er will ihn nicht verlieren. Das hat er so gesagt, als er damals als Trainer angefangen hat. Was er da meint, ist natürlich, dass John-Kanegi so viel Talent hat, ein unfassbarer Fußballer ist. Aber natürlich hat er ganz viele Nebenschauplätze geschuldet, wo er herkommt, was er erlebt hat. Er hat ihn halt nicht aufgegeben und das ist wunderbar. Vor dem Finale hat John-Kanegi seinem Agenten eine Sprachnachricht geschickt, die findet man auch, wenn man ein bisschen sucht, wo er sagt, im Finale schießt er das entscheidende Tor, er holt den Titel. Dann wird er im Spiel im Finale von Fernando Diniz vom Wahrmachen hergerufen, sagt ihm tatsächlich, das kann man auch auf dem Twitter-Account der Libertadores, genau, wenn man Lippen lesen kann, wie wir gut nachvollziehen, sagt er, du schießt jetzt das Tor für den Titel, wechselt ihn ein und der Rest ist im Prinzip Geschichte. Also so ein unfassbar geiles Tor und dann, ach so, natürlich holt er sich dann noch die gelb-rote Karte ab und hat damit halt mit 21… Ja, was soll jetzt noch kommen? Einfach vom Gesamtpaket zu einem Spieler, wo ich einfach richtig Bock drauf habe, dass der so was durch die Decke geht. Und wenn man noch ein bisschen weiter denkt, die Celisau hat ja auch auf der Neuen seit Jahren Probleme. Da ist keine echte Neuen mehr. Und er könnte das so in meiner Vorstellung, in meinem Traum, könnte er diese Position dann doch irgendwie ausfüllen. Das wäre fantastisch. So ein richtiger Typ, extravagant, nicht ganz einfach, aber am Ende des Tages, glaube ich, einfach ein Kicker, der allen Menschen Spaß machen kann. Und deswegen finde ich, ist er so, ja auch wenn er jetzt in der Gruppenphase, glaube ich, kaum gespielt hat, durch seine Leistung so in den K.o. spielen und auch im Finale ist das doch eigentlich der Breakout-Star. Für mich ein kleines Plädoyer für John Kennedy.
Ja, hoffentlich sieht das dann sein neuer Nationaltrainer auch so. Oh, wait, könnte sein, dass das vielleicht eintritt, was du da prognostiziert hast. Andreas, ich weiß nicht, ob du was ergänzen möchtest oder ob du uns noch einen weiteren Shooting Star vorstellen willst.
Na, Joa hat ja schon sehr viele gesagt. Was mir auch noch bei ihm gefallen hat, war, dass er dann am Tag danach hier mit Motorrad, oberkörperfrei, ohne Helm durch die Favela gefahren ist. Das war natürlich auch irgendwie großartig. Ja, ich glaube auch. Ich habe so meine Zweifel. Der Schritt nach Europa bei ihm könnte natürlich auch wieder so ein Karrierebreaker sein, wie das bei so vielen brasilianischen Stürmern ist. Aber ja, hat mir auch sehr gut gefallen und ist definitiv der Shooting Style des Turniers. Da gibt es immer eine Meinung auf jeden Fall. Andre zum Beispiel, den kannte man ja schon, ein Nationalspieler. Geht jetzt wahrscheinlich zu Liverpool, Ines als Shooting Style. Also das passt ja nicht. Er ist der beste Mittelfeldspieler im südamerikanischen Clubfußball. Ihn kann man nochmal erwähnen, weil vielleicht viele Leute ihn nicht so kennen. Und er ist ja auch noch jung. Ansonsten bin ich zwar nicht so der Fan von dem Spiel, aber Valentin Barco einfallen von Bukka, der wahnsinniges fußballisches Potenzial hat. Der aber auch so ein verrückter, bunter Vogel ist irgendwo. Und der jetzt wahrscheinlich, ich gehe auch davon aus, dass der für Bukka kein Spiel mehr macht. Das Manchester City oder auf jeden Fall Premier League scheint es zu werden bei ihm. Der hat da eigentlich angefangen als Linksverteidiger. Ist aber, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das gesehen habt, als in der Liga wurde er mal so richtig schön auseinandergenommen von Giacone, von so einem Flügelspieler bei Rosario Central, der nicht ziemlich abfeiert. Das ist so ein bisschen sein Problem. Er kann halt eigentlich nicht verteidigen. Der ist halt nach vorne, ist ja wirklich grandios und macht auch verrückte Sachen. Nicht immer so einfach, glaube ich, für die Mitspieler. Ist aber totaler Leader mit seinen 19 Jahren, glaube ich. Aber ich glaube, man muss bei ihm halt schauen, welche Position am besten zu ihm passt. Auf jeden Fall muss er mehr offensiv eingesetzt werden, weil ansonsten gerade in Europa, jeden Samstag, jeden Sonntag, jedes Wochenende, nehmen die den auseinander. Aber erst mal so als Fußballer, finde ich, ist er auf jeden Fall einer, der jetzt in der Libertadores auf großer Bühne gezeigt hat, dass er da ist, dass er halt auch in schwierigen Momenten, wo es bei Bukka nicht läuft, Verantwortung übernimmt, trotz der, sagen wir mal, Platzhirsche, die sonst auf dem Platz stehen. Und eigentlich, ja, der wahrscheinlich schon der interessanteste Spieler bei Bukka einfach ist, der beste Fußballer, den sie haben. Aber auch er, sehr schwieriger Charakter, aber Eier ohne Ende. Und diese Kombi aus toller Fußballer und geiler Präsenz macht ihn halt wahnsinnig interessant erstmal.
Aber ganz kurz, war Baku auch derjenige, der vor einer Ecke Ninho irgendwie mit dem Kopf in Ninho reinläuft und Ninho am Hals trifft und dann danach elf Meter für sich reklamiert? Oder war das jemand anders? Verwechsel ich das gerade.
So ein Rotthaarigeist, ich weiß gerade gar nicht die Zähne, die du meinst. So ein etwas nicht besonders groß, eher schmächtiger Typ.
Ich hab's mir irgendwo aufgeschrieben, ich finde gerade die Notiz nicht. War eine dieser kniffligen Szenen, ein kolumbianischer Schiedsrichter hat es übrigens gut gemacht, dieses Finale zu leiten, nicht so einfach. Und das war eine dieser Szenen. Also vielleicht war das Baku.
Aber er hat zum Beispiel beide Pässe gespielt in der ersten Halbzeit, gerade den auf Cavani, das war eigentlich die größte Chance, die Burka hatte im ganzen Spiel. Und er ist halt fußballerisch schon auf einem anderen Level. Aber trotzdem fand ich jetzt mal, er war trotzdem, unterm Strich war ich enttäuscht von seiner Leistung. Auch von Christian Medina, der ist auch ein Spieler, der mir eigentlich gefällt. Der ist aber auch nicht in diese Shooting-Stars. Aber Baku hat jetzt so, das ist halt auch wichtig, für europäische Scouts oder Entscheider zu sehen, wie präsentiert sich einer. Das kommt natürlich nicht gut an, dieses unfaires Spiel. Aber trotzdem, du musst in jungen Jahren, wie diese zwei Jungen, über die wir jetzt geredet haben, mit so einem Selbstvertrauen. Weil es geht ja immer darum, schafft es jetzt dieser Spieler, dieser Latino in dem Falle, schafft er das auch in Europa. Du brauchst einfach willensstarke, selbstbewusste Jungs. Weil es wird nicht immer alles so gut laufen. Nimm Kennedy zum Beispiel aus seinem Umfeld raus. Da kann ja alles passieren. Vielleicht ist das sogar gut für den. Und Baku ist halt auch einer, der muss mal in so eine europäische Top-Team. Und dann braucht er auch mal so einen Leader an seiner Seite, der ihn auch mal ein bisschen in die Schranken weist. Danach, auf dem Platz, wird er auch bei einem europäischen Top-Team einer der besten Fußballer immer bleiben. Aber es geht halt... Das ist halt auch ein Spieler, der geht vorm Tripling, stellt er sich auf den Ball. Solche Sachen auf der Bühne, Libertadores. Das kannst du ja im Grunde nicht machen. Ich meine, das ist ja fast schon Assi. Also, wenn nicht der Verteidiger, dann wirst du den einfach nur noch wegsensen. Aber der findet das auch geil, dieses Provokante. Und schnauzt dann halt auch solche Legenden wie Cavani an, wenn er der Meinung ist, der läuft falsch, der läuft nicht genug oder wie auch immer. Und das ist eine Qualität erstmal. Die muss man natürlich so ein bisschen managen. Aber der Junge hat eigentlich, wie man sagt, der hat kein Dach. Das heißt, der hat Megapotenzial. Aber, wie gesagt, ein bisschen zügeln und man muss für ihn seine Position finden. Und meine Meinung, die des Links-Verteidigers ist es nicht.
Er hat kein Dach. Was für eine schöne Formulierung. Die versuche ich mir auf jeden Fall zu merken. Ich wollte mit euch noch über eure Lieblings-Anekdoten von diesem Turnier sprechen. Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher, ob wir das vielleicht sogar schon mit den besten Spielen mit absolviert haben. Johannes, ist dir was darüber hinaus in Erinnerung geblieben, was wir jetzt noch gar nicht thematisiert haben? Das kann ja auch abseits des Feldes passiert sein.
Da muss ich ein bisschen überlegen. Mir ist noch eine Szene eingefallen, was auch tatsächlich immer wieder passiert und nicht unbedingt für den südamerikanischen Fußball spricht. Aber es war eine K.o.-Partie von International. Ich weiß aber leider nicht mehr, welches Spiel das war, da wurde einfach Tränengas ins Stadion eingedrungen, weil die Polizei das dann auch mal draußen gegen Fans eingesetzt hat und dann reingezogen ist, das Spiel wurde unterbrochen. Fans aus dem Block sind da so ein bisschen geflüchtet, ganz hektische Szenen. Es ging dann auf einmal nach 15 Minuten, warum auch immer, einfach wieder weiter. Aber es sind auch immer wieder natürlich so die äußeren Bedingungen. Vor zwei Jahren, wo die großen Proteste in Kolumbien waren, eigentlich dieselben Szenen. Also außerhalb des Stadions Riesenproteste, Polizeiaufgebot und auch das Tränengas ins Stadion. Das gehört halt auch dazu. Also so ehrlich muss man sein. Das war, was mir noch eingefallen ist. Ansonsten, ich weiß nicht, Andi?
Mir fällt noch ein, als es ja noch Absteiger gab in Argentinien, ist ja mal der Pokalsieger abgestiegen, Patronato, der als Pokalsieger natürlich für die Libertadores sich qualifiziert hat. Und natürlich nicht weitergekommen ist, aber zwei Siege geholt hat, aus der Gruppe, und das fand ich für einen Zweitligist, der personell total neu besetzt war, fand ich das schon gut. Dass man auch noch, vielleicht nicht mehr am 6. Spieltag, aber dass man zumindest noch kurz vor Schluss die Möglichkeit hatte, in die Südamerikaner als Gruppentritter reinzurutschen, das kann man noch mal erwähnen. Das war so meine kleine Mansion an der Stelle. Schade, ich hätte gerne die Mannschaft gesehen, weil die ja total, also Copa Argentina, Boca geschlagen, Riva geschlagen, und zwar nicht glücklich, sondern das war eine Maschiramannschaft, eine Pressing-Resistente, hohes Anlaufen und trotzdem irgendwie so eine Spielkultur. Die sind ja dann abgestiegen über diesen 3-Jahres-Durchschnitt. Die wären ja an sich nicht abgestiegen, wenn es jetzt normal ist, so wie wir das kennen. Abstiegsformat, europäisch, da wären die gar nicht abgestiegen in diesem Jahr. Das fand ich schade, dass sie dann mit so einer komplett neuen Truppe zumindest in eine leichte Gruppe reingekommen sind, aber haben ihre zwei Siege geholt. Das hat mich irgendwie dann auch so ein bisschen gefreut für diesen Provinzklub, will ich es jetzt mal nennen.
Aber kannst du kurz erklären, Abstieg über drei Jahreswertungen? War das jetzt wieder so etwas, was man sich ausgedacht hatte, dass …Ach so.
Das ist schon lange, das ist schon lange so. Du steigst über einen Koeffizienten ab. Da wird halt geschaut, wie viele Punkte machst du geteilt durch die Spiele. Und das ist dein Abstiegskampf. Also du kannst letzter werden und nicht absteigen, wenn du halt deine Jahre davor, deine ein, zwei Saisons davor, wenn die gut waren. Das ist halt auch wieder das. Das gibt es schon lange. Das schützt ja die großen Mannschaften. Weil jeder kann ja mal, so wie Schalke zum Beispiel, kann ja mal absteigen. Wobei, so wie Schalke gespielt hat in den letzten Jahren. Ja, aber das ist schon so. Du kannst ja mal ein schlechtes Jahr haben. Und dann rettet dich quasi der 3-Jahres-Punkte-Durchschnitt. Das ist halt auch so ein Ding, das gehört eigentlich abgeschafft. Das ist totaler Quatsch. Weil es dann halt auch für manche Mannschaften, wenn die dann sehen, ich werde nicht mehr Meister, aber ich steige halt auch nicht ab, dann ist die Saison fast schon gelaufen. Nutzen aber auch wiederum andere Clubs so. Vélez macht das immer mal wieder gerne. Dann schicken die so eine U23 aufs Feld, mal über mehrere Spiele. Das ist dann für deine Jugend, wenn die dann nicht so viel Druck haben, kann auch mal wieder gut sein. Aber letztendlich ist es totaler Quatsch. Und da wird ständig was geändert. Da ist auch manchmal gar nicht so einfach, up-to-date zu bleiben, weil aus ihrem Bauch. Weil zwei Fans nicht zu viel getrunken haben.
Aber wie ist denn das mit den Aufsteigern? Die haben ja noch nicht zwei Jahre da gespielt. Beginnen die dann bei Null? Und bei denen zählt dann der aktuelle Schnitt nur?
Ja, genau. Und der ist natürlich dementsprechend. Du kannst halt schnell hoch, aber auch schnell runter. Weil es ist wirklich deine Punkte geteilt durch die Spiele. Und das ist dann so mit ungefähr 1,0, 1,1, 1,2. Und da steigst du ab. 1,2 reicht wahrscheinlich noch, um drin zu bleiben. Aber das heißt, du kannst als Aufsteiger relativ schnell aus dem Abschicksam heraus, aber relativ schnell auch rein.
Und was ist bei Punktgleichheit? Oder geht es da quasi bis auf die letzte Dezimalstelle, die möglich ist? Weil das wird ja relativ oft dann passieren.
Ja, das haben wir jetzt eventuell. Wir müssen erst mal gucken, ob es denn tatsächlich Aufsteiger gibt. Vor einer Woche hatten wir vier punktgleiche Mannschaften. Wie wird das dann gemacht? Mit Halbfinale, noch mal Finale. Das ist alles. Auch das ist ja schon kurios, wie die Mannschaften absteigen. Und dann musst du dich mal da beschäftigen über diese National-W, die Zweite Liga, wie die aufsteigen. Wie kompliziert das ist mit diesen ganzen Finalspielen. Und dann der Erste gegen den Ersten und dann später noch mal da und dann der Zweite gegen den Achten. Aus der Zone, aus der anderen Zone. Katastrophe. Katastrophe.
Hört sich an wie Belgien. Da muss man mal herausfinden, ob das dieselbe Agentur ist, die damals Belgien und die Schweiz beraten hat bei ihren neuen Playoff-Modalitäten.
Mir ist doch noch eine Anekdote zur Libertadores eingefallen. Und zwar ein Rekord, der gebrochen wurde. Und zwar ein Negativrekord. Alianza Lima, also man muss wissen, der peruanische Vereinsfußball würde ich tatsächlich zusammen mit Venezuela als den schlechtesten Vereinsfußball aktuell bewerten. Bolivien hat durch den Heimvorteil immer wieder Mannschaften im Achtelfinale oder dieses Jahr sogar im Viertelfinale. Das ist schon besser. Und bei Peru ist aktuell nicht viel los. Und Alianza Lima hatte den Rekord, dass sie seit 30 Libertadores-Spielen kein Spiel gewonnen hat. 30. Also immer wieder qualifiziert für die Libertadores, weil sie ja in Peru doch die dominante Mannschaft sind. Immer wieder Meisterschaften gewinnen. Carlos Zambrano spielt da übrigens zur Zeit. Und dann haben sie es hinbekommen, ich glaube, es war sogar das zweite Gruppenspiel gegen Libertad aus Asuncion endlich mal wieder zu gewinnen. 2 zu 1. Nur um dann in der Folge wieder alles zu verlieren und als Letzter auszuscheiden und nicht in der Sudamerikaner auch noch teilzunehmen über den dritten Platz. Melgar, der andere peruanische Verein, auch Letzter. Also da geht nicht viel zusammen. Aber diesen Negativrekord, in Südamerika gibt es ja natürlich auch viele Häme immer. Also so ein Rekord mit 30 Spielen nicht in der Libertadores zu gewinnen, da wirst du ja auseinandergenommen. Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen das, was Fluminense jetzt geschafft hat. Du hast es ganz zu Beginn erwähnt. Von den großen 12 gab es ja nur zwei Vereine, die noch nie die Libertadores gewonnen haben, Botafogo und Fluminense. Jetzt ist es nur noch Botafogo. Schön für Fluminense und katastrophal für Botafogo, die aber nächstes Jahr in der Libertadores mit Sicherheit teilnehmen werden, sind gerade Tabellenführer.
Genau. Sind gerade Tabellenführer.
Ich will auch noch was sagen. Mir ist noch was eingefallen. Und zwar, im Finale haben wir, das war auch ein bisschen kurios, wir haben ja Vicente Taborda gesehen, der reinkam, der kam so die letzte Viertelstunde rein und hat ja dann irgendwie gefühlt 20 Flanken versucht, an den Mann zu bringen. Und das war, was da auch historisch war, das war sein erster Auftritt in der Libertadores. Also du machst ein Debüt im Finale. Das gab es zumindest in der Vereinsgeschichte, zumindest bei Boca gab es das nicht, kann aber in einem anderen Verein so gewesen sein. Was interessant ist bei ihm, er war ja ausgeliehen, an Platense, dann wurde er, wurde die Laie abgebrochen, weil er da gut performt hat und wollte ihn irgendwie in seine eigene Mannschaft integrieren. Hat ihn dann, ich glaube, er hat 200 Minuten gespielt insgesamt für Boca bisher, in der ganzen Serie, also in der Liga, bringt ihn aber dann im Finale, gibt ihm jeden Ball, also ich glaube, in der letzten Viertelstunde, da war ja der Border-Flanke, Abwehr, der Border-Flanke, Abwehr, die ganze Zeit, also gibt ihm diesen Hotspot in einem Finale, wichtigstes Spiel der letzten Jahre, um ihn dann, aber nach einem verlorenen Finale, ins Training der U23 zu stecken. Und das sind auch so Kleinigkeiten bei Boca, hier bei Riquelmes Boca, aber ich sage, was ist das denn für eine Scheiße eigentlich? Was macht ihr eigentlich die ganze Zeit? Also du bringst einen Spieler im Finale, der im Grunde keine Rolle gespielt hat das ganze Jahr bei dir, gibst ihm dann auch jeden, also diesen ganzen Protagonismus. So, hier, du bist jetzt mein Lifesaver im Finale. Und dann klappt das nicht und dann, ja okay, jetzt kannst du wieder zu U23 trainieren gehen. Weiß ich nicht. Ich lasse das jetzt mal unkommentiert.
Moment, du hast schon gesagt, das ist das für eine Scheiße. Ich weiß nicht, ob du es wirklich noch unkommentiert lassen kannst. Okay, damit sind wir ja auch schon so ein bisschen bei den Enttäuschungen des Turniers. Ich glaube, Riva haben wir schon rausgearbeitet. Johannes, die muss man da auf jeden Fall nennen. Oder überinterpretiere ich das jetzt?
Nee, auf jeden Fall. Auch wenn das am Ende unglücklich ist, das Ausscheiden der Anspruch von Riva ist immer –okay, wahrscheinlich immer –zu gewinnen. Das wird nicht immer klappen. Aber Achtelfinale hat nichts mit dem Anspruch von Riva zu tun. Und sind es ja auch eigentlich zu gut für, um da im Achtelfinale auszuscheiden. Flamengo natürlich auch, worüber wir vorhin kurz gesprochen haben, dass sie da in Asuncion rausfliegen, war auf jeden Fall so nicht zu erwarten. In der Gruppenphase waren es dann auch die Corinthians aus Sao Paulo, die dann auch schon früh rausgeflogen sind gegen die Argentinos, die Andi eben so schön gelobt hat. Das waren vielleicht die drei großen Enttäuschungen, würde ich sagen. Als Überraschung im Prinzip auch noch, dass das Bulli war, doch auch Atletico Paranaense rausgekickt hat, noch im Elfmeterschießen. Aber Paranaense ist jetzt auch nicht die Übermannschaft oder die große Supermacht im südamerikanischen Fußball. Letztes Jahr aber Finalist und dann war das Ausscheiden gegen den Bulli schon –also hat mich überrascht auf jeden Fall.
Andi, magst du da noch was ergänzen?
Man könnte noch Paulinho nennen, der Ex-Bayer Leverkusen, eine überragende Quali, so wie bei der Champions League auch. Gibt ja noch Qualirunden vor der Gruppenphase. Sieben Tore, vier Vorlagen in neun Spielen. Stark, stark. Dann der Spiel bei Minedo. Und dann im Achtelfinal gegen Palmeiras war keine Chance. Sind so torlos geblieben in beiden Spielen. Aber für einen Spieler, der hatte ja auch ein paar Kreuzbandgeschichten. Paulinho war ja einige Verletzungen dabei. Das war ja alles so ein bisschen sehr viel verbranntes Geld. Und wieder so eine Geschichte. Auch wenn ich natürlich immer für den argentinischen Fußball bin. Aber das tut mir dann natürlich auch leid. Dieses typische, da hast du einen Brasilianer geholt. Und da siehst du mal, Geld verbrannt, hat nichts gebracht. Und hat mich dann für ihn persönlich gefreut, dass er dann so überragend gestartet ist. Gut, konnten es nicht weiter ausbauen. Aber um nochmal, weil Leute kennen ihn ja noch aus der Bundesliga.
Er wird jetzt auch zum ersten Mal für die Seleção nominiert. Für die Länderspiele im November tatsächlich. Das ist ja auch nochmal so eine Sache, dass Fernando Dinis jetzt als Trainer in der Brasilianischen Liga und Nationaltrainer ist. Es sind jetzt doch überdurchschnittlich viele Spieler aus der Liga auch da. Also 1, 2 gibt es ja eigentlich immer. Meistens der dritte Torwart. Das ist jetzt auch der Fall. Aber dann wurde Paulinho jetzt das erste Mal nominiert. Enrique von Palmeiras. Andre natürlich, sein Fluminense-Mann Rafael Vega von Palmeiras. Hab ich noch jemand vergessen. Aber ja, das nur so als kleine Randnotiz. Also das ist, dass manche Spieler auch in jungen Jahren halt manchmal noch den Schritt tatsächlich nochmal zurück nach Südamerika machen können, machen müssen. Aber dann läuft es auf einmal wieder. Also es gibt ja viele Beispiele. Und Paulinho ist da sicherlich ein.
Hm, 23 Jahre ja erst alt. Dann habe ich noch eine letzte Frage, weil wir jetzt doch wieder bei Dienisch und der Selesao gelandet sind. Du hast vorhin gesagt, Johannes, dass er wahrscheinlich nur für ein Jahr Trainer bleiben wird. Aber ich dachte, das wäre eine ausgemachte Sache, dass er jetzt noch so lange Trainer macht, bis Carlo Ancelotti übernimmt.
Naja, solange –das muss man wissen –kein Vertrag unterschrieben, ist es alles möglich.
Aber es ist noch kein Vertrag unterschrieben.
Es ist noch kein Vertrag unterschrieben. Es ist der brasilianische Verbandspräsident. Er hat das in einem Interview schon so gesagt, dass Ancelotti Trainer wird. Ancelotti hat da meines Wissens noch nichts zugesagt. Auch wenn jetzt Brasilien im Oktober zu Hause gegen Venezuela verloren hat, auch Riesen-Blamage eigentlich. Deswegen kann es sein, dass sich da gerade der Vibe wieder ein bisschen ändert. Aber die Fernandes-Diniz hat eine Riesen-Unterstützung tatsächlich in Brasilien. Eben wegen diesem neuen Spielgefühl, was er da wegen diesen neuen taktischen Ansätzen und auch seiner Person, so seinen Umgang mit Spielern. Er ist ja gelernter Psychologe und hat auch einen ganz, ganz besonderen Umgang einfach mit Spielern. Weiß auch, wie er mit schwierigen Charakteren umgehen kann und das so alles in der Kombination. Für mich muss er der Trainer der Selesao sein, aber man will ja immer ein bisschen mehr. Und natürlich ist Carlo Ancelotti natürlich jetzt auch kein Trainer. Genau, das könnte natürlich auch klappen. Aber ich weiß nicht, mein Gefühl ist, dass Diniz Trainer bleiben muss. Aber wahrscheinlich wird es Ancelotti.
Wobei die Serie auch gerissen ist für Brasilien. Die Qualifikationsspiele waren seit 2015 oder 2016 ungeschlagen. Und jetzt gegen Bielsa und Uruguay haben sie verloren. Und gegen Venezuela nicht gewonnen. Was war das? Unschihen gegen Venezuela und gegen Uruguay verloren. Ja, werden wir mal sehen. Denn Denise hatte auch nicht überall Erfolg. Er kommt jetzt stark bei Fluminense, aber er hatte auch andere Stationen, die nicht immer so gut gelaufen sind. Ich sage mal, wenn du Ancelotti haben kannst, holst du. Außer er brilliert jetzt noch mit der Célizau. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob er vor dem nächsten Turnier die Möglichkeit hat.
Zeit hat man ja sowieso nicht in Brasilien auf der Trainerposition. Das ist ja absurd, wie oft die Trainer gewechselt werden. FC Santos hat jetzt für diese Saison bereits den vierten Trainer. Das ist natürlich in der Célizau noch ein bisschen konservativer. Aber Zeit hat es nicht. Und jetzt mit den Ergebnissen ist es natürlich auch kritisch. Und man will wieder Weltmeister werden. Und dann holt es am Ende doch wahrscheinlich Angelotti. Also das ist auch die wahrscheinlichere Variante, dass er da Trainer werden wird, um das nochmal so ein bisschen aufzulösen. Aber von der brasilianischen Spielidee und Spielidentität finde ich schon, dass das der richtige Mann ist.
Ja, interessant. Ich dachte, es wäre schon alles ausgemacht, so wie man ja auch schon dachte, es wäre ausgemacht, dass Xabi Alonso dann von Leverkusen zu Real Wechselt. Vielleicht sollten wir alle da, inklusive mir, einen Schritt zurücktreten und erst mal warten, bis Verträge unterschrieben sind.
Du hast recht, es wird auch überall so geschrieben, dass das in Stein gemeißelt ist. Und wie gesagt, dadurch, dass der Verbandspräsident das auch so gesagt hat. Also es gibt wahrscheinlich eine mündliche Vereinbarung, das wahrscheinlich schon, aber Vertrag ist noch nicht unterschrieben.
Okay, also dann warten wir das alles ab. Und ich empfehle allen Hörern und Hörern zwei Dinge. Zum einen werde ich in den Show Notes ein Video verlinken zum Fußball, den ihr spielen lässt. Relationism ist das, wie man es jetzt genannt hat, wurde von Malmö auch schon so zum Teil übernommen. Aber da gibt es ein paar sehr gute YouTube-Videos, die das gut erklären, was daran das Besondere ist. Und dann verlinke ich euch auf jeden Fall auch nochmal den YouTube-Kanal der Copa. Denn da kann man eben die ganzen Highlights nochmal sehen der Spiele, wenn auch leider nicht mit Kommentar. Das fand ich sehr schade an der Stelle. Ist mir doch egal, dass ich den nicht verstehe. Wenn er dann Goalschreit, dann spätestens setzt mein Verständnis wieder ein. So fremdsprachengewandt bin ich. Aber da kann man sich die Highlights nochmal angucken. Und ich werde mir unter anderem dieses Elfmeterschießen mit dem kaputten Elfmeterpunkt. Das werde ich mir jetzt nochmal geben, wenn das hier alles online ist. Ihr zwei, ich danke euch sehr herzlich. Ihr habt euch sehr, sehr viel Zeit genommen. Das weiß ich wirklich sehr zu schätzen. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an Andreas Geipel. Add fun the Geip auf Twitter. Ich weiß nicht, ob du auch schon auf Blue Sky oder woanders bist. Noch nicht. Dann verlinke ich weiter deinen Twitter-Händel. Danke dir, Andreas, dass du mal wieder hier warst.
Sehr gerne, sehr gerne.
Und ebenfalls mit dabei Johannes Skiba, der add-Bayeres-jo, so heißt du, auf Twitter. Ich glaube auch aktuell nur auf Twitter aktiv.
Ja, ich habe schon Blue Sky-Account mir angelegt, aber den noch nicht bespielt. Also vorerst weiterhin auf Twitter unterwegs.
Ich werde dich natürlich auch verlinken. Und man kann bei Goal Olympico dich auch immer reden hören. Danke dir, dass du hier im Rasenfunk mit dabei warst.
Ja, sehr gerne. Dankeschön auch an Andi, auch an dich, dass wir hier mal endlich wieder so ein bisschen über Fußball Südamerika reden können. Es ist immer so ein Podcast, das ist auch immer so ein Ventil. Man hat ja Freunde, aber die wenigsten davon interessieren sich für südamerikanische Fußball.
Die kotzen über dazwischen. Beim Podcast kann man einfach so vor sich hin. Ich würde gerne Böseelzungen behaupten, das sei der Grund, warum es den Rasenfunk gibt. Also danke euch beiden und danke allen Hörerinnen und Hörern da draußen. Das hier war die Ligatur. Wenn euch das gefallen hat, unterstützt uns gerne. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Und schaut gerne auch auf rasenfunk.de, was wir sonst noch so für Sendungen machen. Also es wird morgen noch was erscheinen, zum zweiten Männerbundesliga zum Beispiel. Wir haben natürlich den Frauen- und den Männerbundesligaspieltag aufgearbeitet. Es gibt Borussia Dortmund Schwerpunkt. Alles am Montag erschienen. Also so einiges zu hören im Rasenfunk. Danke für eure Zeit. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bleibt gesund. Bis bald. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.